do you need another key for your honda
vehicle if you only have one key for the
vehicle
starts the engine i'm going to show you
how you can use tom's car key programmer
to make additional keys for your honda
vehicle check out this key it's been
held together with a rubber band it's
falling apart maybe you have a key like
this it doesn't even have any remote
buttons and you want to get a key that
has buttons to lock and unlock the door
well we can help you with that in this
process well i'm mike with tomski
company let me show you how easy it is
to use our programming device to get
another key made for your honda vehicle
come visit our website tomsky.com place
an order and we'll get you set up with
another key at a fraction of the cost of
car dealership charges let's take a look
to save you the time and hassle of
driving all around trying to find a
hardware store locksmith or car
dealership to cut your new key
we created our key by photo service yeah
you heard that right from your picture
we'll cut your new key before it ships
stick around to the end to learn more
but this vehicle only has a key with no
remote buttons we're going to be adding
remote buttons to it we called the honda
dealership gave him the vin number and
asked if it came with a trunk button or
without a trunk button originally and
this one came with trunk button so
everything should be working when we're
done this original key i've got a tile
key finder you might want to pick one of
these up on the website protect your
investment
it pairs with your smartphone and then
you can always figure out where your
keys are at even if you've left them
somewhere you can look on the map and
find out a great little device
so included in your order you have the
installation device
whatever new keys you order in this case
it's already come cut with our key by
photo technology heads up the printed
manual is going away instead easy to
follow online instructions are being
rolled out so grab a smartphone and it
will walk you through each step of the
key pairing process make sure you use
read through this user guide
in advance get familiar with it there's
some timing requirements
you want to turn off your hvc your
lights anything that'll drain the
battery inside you need to look at the
chart
and find for your vehicle in this case
we have 2012 honda civic
activation code of three one one
primary dial position of one alternate
dial position of number two we need to
turn to dial position number one
to get our programmer ready to go
all right we're gonna begin our
programming by taking our working key
and it's important to note you must have
a working key that starts the vehicle to
use our programming equipment we're
going to take our working key
put it in turn the engine to the on
position don't start the engine we need
to take our easy installer as long as
there's no silver letters here saying
void the programmers should be good to
go for your vehicle with the engine on
we're plugging in a programmer come down
by a gas and brake pedal
look around until you find the obd2 port
this guy right here
and plug the programmer in
you'll hear it beep as it gets plugged
in
here beep twice
the first step is pressing and releasing
the button on the end here
it beeped once
and beep twice more
we're gonna remove the key insert the
new key there's our new key
put it in turn it to the on position do
not start the engine
it beeps twice
if you notice on the dashboard there's a
blinking green light looks like a key
turn off the ignition it'll beep
turn it on with the same key do not
start the engine after 10 seconds it'll
beep twice
there we go
turn the ignition off
it beeps
turn the ignition on
with the same key
plays its happy tune notice the green
light has turned off
and with that this key is programmed
get the programmer unplugged
you'll know the new key is programmed
when you insert
and turn the engine on the green
security light does not stay on or blink
now also pay attention to this in
programming the key we've programmed the
remote buttons as well
trunk
panic
okay everything works look at that
wasn't that easy to go from having a key
with no buttons
now we got one that has buttons and it
works for the vehicle second key that's
how easy it is for tom's key company to
help you and make extra keys for your
vehicle you can save a bunch of money
over the cost of car dealership wanted
to charge so
if you got a quote from a dealership
leave a comment down below let people
know how much it costs for you and once
you've used our solution let others know
how easy it is for tom's key company to
help you make more keys for your vehicle
now we provide great customer service
you can reach us help tomsky.com if you
run into problems there's also a
toll-free number in the instruction
manual for technical support if you're
running into issues while you program
your keys and finally we offer a full
money back guarantee so if this doesn't
work for your vehicle
don't worry about it send us an email
and we'll try to help you out if we
still can't get it working we'll give
all your money back it's that easy let
me tell you more about our amazing key
by photo service add that to your cart
then you simply upload photos of your
existing key once you check out
and will cut your new keys so they
arrive all ready to fit your vehicle so
you can go right into programming
now if you order the key by photo
service when it arrives
check the fit turn it over make sure it
turns the lock
from both sides of the key if for some
reason it's not fitting reach out to us
help tomsky.com
let us know send some photos your of
your existing key and the new one and
we'll get it taken care of for you we've
got solutions for a ton of different
vehicles on our website
so come visit us tomsky.com